The period in which the Greek pulleys
were left essentially to their own
devices,
came to an end with the clash
between the Persian empire and,
uh, that some of the Greek city
states, uh, but which came to involve,
uh,
Athens at the famous battle
of marathon in four 19.
And I'd like to tell you today about the,
the rise of the Persian empire and it's
conflict with the Greek st concluding
with the account of that battle.
The Persians, uh, first
some terminology, uh,
the Persians were what the, uh,
thanks very much. Well, what the, um,
the Greeks called them
and that was appropriate.
They were very close cousins
of the people who lived,
uh, right next to them or among
them called the Medes. In fact,
the Medes where the first
of that group of, uh,
I guess we could call
them, um, Arion people's.
Again, that's a term
that has been abused, uh,
throughout the 19th and 20th century.
Applying to as though
it was a racial group.
The term is a linguistic one,
and they spoke a branch of the
Indo European family of languages,
which is designated as Arion.
Uh,
and that's all that really means, but
they're very, very close. In fact,
the Greeks really couldn't distinguish
between the Persians and the errands and
so,
um,
they call them sometimes needs in some
time between the Medes and the Persians,
I mean, and sometimes they call them means
and sometimes they call them Persians.
It really doesn't matter because although
the Medes took the lead in forming a
national kingdom out of a tribal society
and we're the first to be the dominant
family on the Iranian plateau where
these people finally settled down,
the Persians then overthrew
them and establish themselves
as the ruling group in
that family under Cyrus the great as
he was called back probably in five 59,
he was called Cyrus the great
because he was a great conqueror.
First making his tribal associates,
the Persians,
the dominant force in Iran,
and then expanding the extent and the
power of what we can now call the Persian
empire and extraordinary distance.
If we look at the end of the lifetime
of Cyrus one man's lifetime is when this
extraordinary expansion, much
of it, most of it takes place.
If you look at the Near
East in the year five 50 BC,
what you find is the Kingdom of media,
the Kingdom of Babylonia,
which is the most powerful one
in the Tigris, Euphrates valley,
what is now Iraq,
the Kingdom of Lydia occupying sort
of the western portion of Asia minor
excluding at first the coast,
which was occupied by Greeks,
but which the Lydians then
conquer the Greeks, uh,
in the five forties, um,
that, but that's the picture.
And then there is the,
the people of Persia, the Persians
themselves who are of not much account.
But when Cyrus becomes king in five 59,
he is a member of the dynasty,
which is the [inaudible] dynasty.
And he conquers his fellow Aryans the
needs and about five 15 and very swiftly
conquers Babylonia. Armenia, Syria,
Kappa Dosha, which is another
kingdom in Central Asia Minor,
uh,
and has already expanded this a kingdom
to something pretty much unexampled up
to that time.
Now.
Meanwhile in Lydia,
the dynasty that began back in the seventh
century finds that the king creases
is the monarch in the, at that point, uh,
you will have remembered of course,
that Hurghada is his first book,
pretty much begins its story with a King
creases and his decision to attack the
Persian empire,
which is now on his frontier,
a new old member. The story
that Herat Herat, it just tells.
So charmingly the,
a story of how it increases,
decides he wants to
conquer the Persian empire.
Consults the article of Apollo at Delphi
to see how he's going to make out the
article gives a characteristically
enigmatic answer,
but he doesn't recognize the
enigma, the answer. He says,
what will happen if I crossed the Halley's
river? That's the boundary between, uh,
uh, Lydia, which had been, I'm sorry,
between Lydia and the Persian territory,
uh,
the article answers a great
empire will be destroyed.
And of course he had in mind
destroying the Persian empire. Instead,
the person's destroyed his empire.
And of course that shows you,
you've got to ask the right question and
keep answering until you get an answer.
You understand? Well, um,
quizzes, attacks, uh, in five 47,
his capital of Sardis falls into the
hands of the Persians in the next year.
And so now the Persians are in
control of the Lydian Empire.
And uh, in, uh,
on the frontiers of the Greek
cities on the coast of Asia Minor.
And the conquest of those
cities takes place in the years.
Five 46 to five 39,
five 39 is a very big year for
the Persians because in that year,
they conquer the city of Babylon
and thereby gained control of all of
Mesopotamia.
Another one of the major
expansions of this vast empire,
the successor to,
uh,
Cyrus is a cam by cs.
And in the years between
five 30 and five 22,
he conquers amazingly
enough the Kingdom of Egypt,
perhaps the oldest,
but certainly if not almost the
oldest of the kingdoms of that region,
fantastically wealthy
and in its own right,
formerly a great empire.
Now,
if you stop in five 22,
when cam by sees dies,
you see that the Persian empire extends
on the West from the Aegean Sea and the
Mediterranean Sea.
To the West all the way to the
Indus River in what is now Pakistan.
And I'm from the south to really to,
um,
what is now Sudan at the southern end of
the Nile river and up north to include
the European coast of the Hellespont
and the region and the waters that the
straights and the
European coast of the GNC.
And,
um,
he comes right up as far as the Danube
River and nor is that the end of what he
would like to do,
can buy these launches,
an invasion of the
territory beyond the Danube,
which was not in the,
in the shape of any kind
of a national kingdom yet.
Just an area filled with
different kinds of tribes,
which the Greeks called Scythians
pushing all the way back into Russia,
all the way back to the Caucasus
mountains and perhaps beyond these,
um, uh, horse riding, um,
tribal people called the Scythians who
didn't even really engage in agriculture.
But we're still in the business of,
of living off a herds of animals.
Well, the, uh, the
expedition goes forward.
It ends up gaining the straits and
massive don, as I told you before,
or I should have told you
those names. Anyway. Um,
the story is told that one of the generals
of the Persian army is a certain mill
tighties mill.
Tyrese was originally an Athenian,
but his family had been expelled.
And the time of the time I'll rather
they had been sent to govern the
Gallipoli's peninsula,
the Thracian curse Denise as
the Greeks called it. And uh,
so he lived up there and then when the
Persians came and took that territory,
he became a subject of the great king
and he became a general in the great
king's army.
He and some others were given the task
of guarding the bridges across the Danube
while the king was chasing,
assessing Ian's on the other side.
Well, he was unable to defeat the
Scythians who used Scythian tactics,
which is to say on cavalry,
stayed away,
avoided a direct conflict,
and did damage, um,
with missiles at a distance and
ran away when they couldn't,
uh, when they were about to
face a great Persian army,
which could defeat them.
So he was gone a long time and
while he was gone, no tidy,
said he'll never come back.
Why don't we just break down these bridges
to make sure we never gets back and
then we'll be free of the Persians. Well,
it didn't work out that way. And the, uh,
the city,
Mississippi and campaign didn't succeed,
but the Persian army came back and a
mill tighties had to run off and escape
because there was certainly a price on
his head and he ended up going back to
Athens where we will run into him again.
So,
um,
that is the situation when we get
to the turn of the fifth century.
The Persians are in control.
They have gained mastery of all
the Greek states of Asia Minor.
The typical relationship between those
cities and the king of Persia was the
same as all of his subjects.
He insisted in every case that the
defeated states who came under his power
should give earth and water to him as a
symbol of their complete subjection to
him.
There was no kind of relationship to
the great king except of one of complete
subject subjugation.
The Greeks regarded that
relationship as one of slavery.
Um, but as a matter of fact, the Persians
were not harsh rulers for the most part.
All they required of the subject peoples
was that they should pay a tribute to
the king. And it was obviously
not one that couldn't be met.
Obviously nobody likes to
pay a tax, especially to a
foreign conqueror. But, uh,
it wasn't something that,
uh,
destroyed the economy and to do military
or naval service at his command and
under his command as well.
So those,
if you did that,
they left too long
at this point of the,
um,
the characteristic regime was to
have a tyranny appointed by the,
the great king of Persia in each
Greek city. But you should remember,
I use that word and its original concept.
It doesn't mean they were harsh.
It doesn't mean they were particularly
cruel. They were the satraps,
the representatives of
the king in that region,
and they had absolute control. But, uh,
we don't hear about any specially
harsh treatment of anybody.
That's the situation when we will come
very shortly to the beginning of conflict
between the Greeks of the mainland
and the Persian empire when the Ionian
rebellion breaks out.
But before that happens,
we need to go back to Greece
and see what's going on there.
[inaudible] remember in Athens,
the Cli Stenek Revolution has taken place.
The new hoplite democracy that I have
described to you is brand new and very
insecure,
fearful that there are enemies within.
Some of them are friends
of the, uh, uh, the,
um,
Arab Socratic families that have been
defeated and fled some of them friends,
relatives of the tyrants whose loyalty
to the new regime is not clear.
So that's one fear.
Another fear is that the Spartans will
not accept their expulsion and the
expulsion of their friends.
But we'll come back again with an army
to try to conquer Athens and turn it over
to the rest of Kratz.
And yet a third problem,
Athenian neighbors with whom the Athenians
have old quarrels may take advantage
of their beleaguered situation and attack
them. So that's has to be remembered.
Athens is in a very insecure spot.
And Herodotus tells us,
excuse me,
that in these circumstances,
the Athenians attempt to get help by
sending a mission to the king of Persia,
asking for an alliance with Persia as
a way of fending off these troubles.
And of course the king only knows
one relationship with other states.
He doesn't know anything about
alliances that have any, uh,
equality associated with them.
He asks the ambassadors of the Greeks,
sorry, of Athens to give him earth and
water and then they can be friends.
Uh, the ambassadors say,
okay, we'll do that.
But when they come back to Athens,
the Athenians are outraged
that they have done so.
They punish the embassy and there is
no relationship between Persia and the
Athenians and indeed what
they feared it happens.
The Spartans invade Attica.
And as they are doing that,
they are joined by other states who
have their own grievances with Attica,
be Osha,
led by thieves.
CALC II switches the city and you'll
be here just to the east of Attica and
current just down the
road on the [inaudible],
they are all going to
attack the Athenians.
But it turns out that the
Corinthians Balk at this,
uh,
idea.
And what they don't like they say is
the notion of installing some kind of a
tyranny in Athens.
They have had the experience of tyranny.
They have expelled the type
activity not so very long ago.
They claim and they are not about to,
uh,
join anybody in doing the same thing.
So that's one source of,
um,
division that prevents this coalition
from attacking the Athenians.
But there's also a quarrel between the
two spartan kings Coriani's who has been
there before and who very much wants to
take Athens in maternity to his arrows,
Socratic friends and kingdom or
[inaudible] who for whatever reason is not
willing to do that demo rate as loses
the argument he is finally charges are
brought against them and he flees.
And next we will find them demo radius
in the Persian empire at the elbow,
sometimes of the king and uh,
giving him advice as to how
to deal with the situation.
Well, because of these
things, there is no invasion.
The Athenians are now free
to turn against the other.
They're neighbors who have
threatened them against the B ocean.
City's led by thieves against cal keys
and the Athenians defeat their opponents
in cal keys on the island of Euboea,
the Athenians take away a chunk of land
from the child Citians and plant 4,000
Athenian settlers on that land.
And they do so not as a colony
in the traditional sense,
not as an appboy Kia,
but as what the Greeks call a clearer key,
which is this,
these 4,000 Athenians who take
the land settle there permanently,
but they remain Athenians.
They are still Athenian citizens.
They are really functioning as an Athenian
garrison to see to it that things in
Biasha are okay in this way.
They very closely resembled
the Roman idea of a colony,
which was typically typically a
collection of veterans after putting after
conquering some other town in Italy,
they would take some of that land,
give it to Roman legionaries and let
them settled permanently there as a
garrison on behalf of the Romans.
Well, that's what the Athenians do.
In the case of, uh, uh, calculus
orotic this sort of sings in Aria at this
point about the wonders of freedom in
which he says the Athenians were no
better than any other Greeks at warfare
before they became free.
But once having liberated themselves
from tyranny and establishing this new
Kleist Stenek regime,
they were able to defeat
all of their opponents.
And so, uh, so much for the erotic,
this is prejudice. But of course,
as you read his sister, you will
realize that in, in one sense,
at least the,
uh,
the history of Hurghada is a on to the,
the wonders of freedom and the greatness
of freedom and this and [inaudible] of
freedom as the story of the Greeks.
Um,
by the way,
he also praises not just freedom
Eleuthera Rhea is the Greek word,
but in the case of Athens,
he praises it's east say goal Rhea.
That word really means equality of speech.
He characterizes this new class, authentic
regime, not by the word democracy,
which is apparently not
really been coined yet,
but rather as what characterize
it is that all citizens are free,
equally able to address the populace
in the assembly and thereby the take an
active role in their own government.
So he's really praising autonomy,
self-government,
not merely freedom from an alien people,
but freedom within the city for all
the people to govern themselves.
He thinks that's one of the reasons why
the Athenians have become so good at
warfare because of these changes.
Now,
a new coalition emerges also
hostile to this new Athenian regime.
It includes Athens old enemy,
the island of [inaudible],
which sits in the,
uh,
ceramic Gulf right opposite
the Athenian coast. Um,
and it, it has, as I say,
they have been fighting each other now
for more than a century and quarreling
about this and that.
So the,
each and Eton's join with the Spartans
and now they are openly attempting to
destroy this regime and to replace it
with a return to the tyranny of hippies.
Hippiest has also fled to the Persians
and is protected by the king so that you
have the notion of having,
um,
even if the Persians get involved,
they too, and they will get involved.
We'll want to put hippiest
on the throne in Athens,
but the Spartans want to do the same
thing. And again, the Corinthians,
we'll have none of that because
of their attitude towards chairmen
now threatened even more severely,
the Athenians send a second mission to
Persia and this time the Persian king
makes it very clear that will require
that the Athenians put down their newly
established democracy and restore
hippiest to his tyranny in Athens,
which would make Athens like
the other Greek city states,
the ones that are on the
coast of Asia Minor, uh,
part of the Persian empire and hippiest
in his relationship to pressure would be
the sand trap of the great
king governing his own city,
which was I think commonly what was
happening in Asia minor on the Greek coast
too.
That's where we are.
When the Ionian rebellion
breaks out in the year for 99,
the start comes in the city of my Litas,
which was of course a leading city of
the Greeks of that area for some long
time,
a place you will remember that was
filled with new ideas where we first hear
about the kinds of quasars scientific.
But in any case,
rationalistic revolution that challenges
the traditional Greek way of thinking
based largely on mythology and
on theology with pure reason.
I don't want to suggest that the my
legion philosophers were without religion.
I'm simply saying they were introducing
something new that stands on the side of
religion and when it comes to their
attempt to explain what they are trying to
explain the physical universe,
for the most part,
it really does put aside religious
concepts and replace them with observation
and reason as the way to do things.
So what we are seeing of course in
my latest is the birth of philosophy.
At the same time as we are seeing
the birth of, um, natural science.
And these do not get separated until many,
many,
many years later on.
They are together.
That's the city where the
rebellion starts, has nothing
to do with philosophers.
It has to do with the tyrant of my
leaders and my lesion by the name of Eris
taggers who gets into
trouble with the great king.
He has talked the great king
into an expedition that he
wanted to launch against
the island of neck
sauce in the Aegean Sea.
He says his knack sauce is a cinch. It's
a nice fat place. They're not ready.
If we sail now secretly I'll be able to
quickly take the island and the great
king. We'll have another, um,
uh, expansion of his empire.
And of course,
Arrowstar rigorous would benefit both
financially and also by the presumed honor
that he would gain from the great
king. Unfortunately, uh, they're,
um, intelligence per, it's the secure,
the security procedures were inadequate
and what he was up to gut to Naxos
before he did.
And the next scions we're ready.
He was defeated and uh,
the great king was not
pleased era staggers,
knew he was in a lot of trouble.
And so he decided that this was the time
for the Greeks of Asia minor to acquire
their freedom from the Persians.
And he was obviously a very persuasive
talker and went around to the various
Greek cities and was able to persuade
most of them to join in the rebellion,
which is indicative of course if the
fact that they were not happy in their
position as subjects of the great king.
So they rebel against the tyrants who
have been collaborating with the great
king.
And this is an interesting point,
they establish democracies
now since as far as we know,
there is no democracy in the world
and it never has been before the one
established in Athens
just a few years ago.
I think there's a lot of reason to think
that the idea of doing that came from
Athens. And that is easily believable
when you realize that Athens,
as I've told you before,
is an Ionian city just as these cities,
my elitist and the other towns that
they get to join them at first,
our Ionian cities and the Athenians are
recognized by the other own Ionians as
the leading Ionian city.
So that all of that makes me think that
it's hard to avoid the conclusion that
it's Athenian democracy that is the
model for these rebellious Ionian states.
But Agora stagger was,
knows that he's going to be facing a
formidable enemy in the forces of the
Persian empire.
And so he goes back to mainland
Greece to seek help for his,
uh,
undertaking.
And the first place you're going to go
if you want military assistance in the
Greek world, of course, is
Sparta. And there indeed, he goes,
uh, again, charming stories that
our auditors tells about it.
He goes to King [inaudible]
and he tells him he would, uh,
what he's trying to do and he tells him
how rich the Persian empire is and how
if they are successful in this rebellion,
they will be able to see
some of the wealth in the
territory of the Persian king.
And won't that be nice for clay nominees
and perhaps with the Spartans as well.
Uh, clean. How many's um,
he says, well, I dunno know,
he sort of scratches his head
and, and uh, he says, uh,
how far is the Capitol of Persia from
your city on the coast of the GNC?
And a bearish staggers is sharp
shrude cookie. And so he says,
I'm glad you asked me this question.
And he pulls out the first recorded map
in all of Greek history and presumably
unrolls it. And he chose you.
You see, here's my leaders.
And then there's this royal road
and if you take it down here,
here is a Souza, the capital
of the Persian. This is,
how far is that?
How will the,
how long would it take me to
march from the coast to there?
He says three months clean.
When he says stranger,
get out of town by duck.
The idea of suggesting to
the Spartans that they,
they should launch an expedition across
a c, which will then take them the army,
they take their army three months,
March away from the coast,
not to mention from Sparta
leaving the city of course,
open to a hell lot rebellion all the time.
They're gone.
That is not a very welcome suggestion.
So Aricept egret says, well, you know,
it's not really so bad. They
got this good road. Uh, besides,
I have here some several Minai of
silver that are glad to give to you.
Might want to think again.
Uh,
and he keeps raising the amount that he's
prepared to bribe clean nominees at a
certain point.
Clean nominees.
Little daughter Gorgol has been
sitting there all the time.
And being a spartan girl,
she gets to up to her father and says,
father,
ask this man to leave at
once or he will corrupt you.
Clay nominees accepted the admonition
from his nine year old daughter and sent
[inaudible] away.
So the effort to gain spartan
support in this rebellion fail.
Well, error Segrest says, okay, I'll
go, I'll try Athens now. It happens.
Of course he's got a much
better shot in the first place.
Athens is an Ionian city,
unlike the Dorian Spartan second place.
Athens sits on the
seashore closer to Persia,
right on the GNC and obviously can feel
that there is a certain danger that
might be coming from Persia in any case,
just because the Persians keep expanding
and they're now sitting right on the
Aegean Sea.
So for these reasons,
and perhaps others maybe were already,
I was going to suggest maybe they were
already involved with Arrow staggers and
the, uh, the rebels of the,
the Greek cities of Asia minor
because of the democracy,
uh, idea. That gives me the suggestion
that has been some communication anyway,
whether that's true or not,
the Athenians vote to send a fleet and
soldiers to assist my us and the other
cities in their rebellion
and they sinned. Well, I'll,
I'll come back to how much they send in
a moment or auditors decides it's time
to make a point.
He says,
this shows how much easier it is to
deceive many people rather than one.
Because by his count,
and this camp has got to be wrong,
there were 30,000 Athenians who
were involved in this decision.
That's certainly far too many.
Um,
and they were fooled by aristocracy,
whereas King Clay,
how many's the one man was not.
Um,
however that may be what the Athenians
wroted was the Sans 20 ships. Now,
scholars,
some scholars have said only 20 ships.
The only is really, I think, a
mistake. They are led to that.
By knowing that later
in the fifth century,
the Athenians will end
up having 400 triremes.
But that's many years later.
That's after a victory over the Persians.
That's in a totally new world.
The best guests I would have now is that
the older ships the Athenians had were
maybe 50.
So sending 20 was not
a trivial contribution.
Why did they do it? Well, for
all the reasons I've suggested,
they care about the Ionians, they are
their relatives in their own mind.
Moreover,
they are not very friendly to Persia
after the exchanges they have had with the
great king in which it's clear,
the only way to deal with the great
king is to become his subject,
something they're not eager to do.
Another thing that we need to take into
account is that the Athenians remember,
at least back to the time of so long and
possibly before have been increasingly
engaged in trade with the east.
That is to say with Asia Minor,
with the Hellespont Sea of Marmara,
the Bosphorus beyond that,
into the Black Sea,
in other words,
into territory bordering on the Persians
so that they have to feel that if the
Persians are unfriendly or if the,
if the Persians just do what
comes naturally to them,
they soon may be interfering
with things that we need.
We increasingly need.
The thing is will be increasingly
dependent on grain and a fish from those
waters. So the, uh,
all of that can explain why the Athenians
are willing to take this enormously
risky decision when the Spartans of
course wouldn't think of doing it.
Heraclitus has this wonderful phrase
to describe the Athenian decision.
These ships were the beginning of
evils to the Greeks and the barbarians.
I guess what he's really saying is here
we have the beginning of the Persian
wars. My subject, the Ionian
rebellion is one thing.
Theoretically,
if the Athenians had minded their own
business and not assisted the rebels,
then there need not
have been a Persian war.
Heaven knows would have come what
motive come next. But in any case,
I think eroticism is saying once the
Athenians decided to participate,
assist the rebellion of
their relatives in Iowa.
This was the beginning of
the Persian wars for Athens.
Well,
the 20th Athenian ships land in my leaders
and their soldiers march inland very
swiftly and reach the city of Sardis,
which is the capital of
the sat trappy of Lydia,
which is a now a Persian province and
are successful in defeating the forces
that come out against them and
set fire to the city of Sardis.
So they've done real harm. Having
done that, the Athenians, oh,
I forgive me, I've left out in
a small but important point.
The Athenians were joined by a few
ships provided by the city of Eretria,
another town in northern Euboea
and old time rival and an enemy of,
um, uh, what's that
other town up there? Uh,
just mentioned it a moment ago.
It's gone right out of my head.
What does anybody remember what town
that is? Calico's thank you very much.
[inaudible] they're old enemies of
calculus and that may account for why very
eager to help the Athenians,
uh,
because the Athenians have defeated kiss
and are keeping the child citians down.
In any case, they do. A few red trians.
20 ships of Athenians
accomplished this deed of, uh,
doing considerable harm to the great
kings position there and Lydia.
Well,
now the Persians launch a thorough going
expedition with the intention of uh,
subduing there Ionian subjects and
bringing them back to subjugation.
Well, it's not all that easy. This
rebellion takes place in for 99.
The war against Persia
doesn't end until four 94.
What the Persians are doing is laying
siege to the city's one by one and taking
them one by one and then
attacking from the sea.
And that was critical.
If they could defeat the fleets of the
Greek cities having already surrounded
them on the land side.
Those cities were out of business and
would have to surrender. And in four,
nine before the fleet,
but the Persians gathered the
Persians of course were landlubbers.
They had no navy of their own,
but they had a very considerable
navy provided by the,
uh,
Phoenicians,
who were among the earliest of the
sailors of the eastern Mediterranean,
whom this the Persians had conquered.
And the Egyptians who had
a naval tradition as well.
So there was a big Egyptian contingent,
a big Phoenician contingent.
And when they were under Persian rule,
the Ionians provided ships
for the great king too.
They weren't available right now that
we're going to be fighting against the
great king.
But that's where he got his forces from.
They were numerically superior and they
were very good sailors and horseman.
So finally at the battle of La de la De,
uh,
off the coast,
off the coast that is on the coast
of Asia minor, nearby, elitist,
the Persians destroyed the fleet of
the Greeks and put down the rebellion.
And then they took vengeance for
the whole thing by laying waste.
The city of my Litas entirely burning it
to the ground as best one could do that
in those days.
So the Ionian rebellion has come
to an inglorious conclusion.
What next?
What next is determined in considerable
part by the internal affairs of the city
of Athens?
Do you see meetings?
They're going to be the most troubled by
what has happened and also they have a
reason to be trouble.
The great king like I,
this is true of most any great empire and
the great power that has been attacked
or even insulted by some smaller state.
You just can't let that go by.
You must punish that action to deter
similar behavior in the future.
So the Athenians had every reason to
fear and invasion or some sort of attack
from the Persians in the future.
I think that is a critical
for understanding what's
going on in Athens in these
years and we do have a few glimpses,
just a few glimpses that are difficult
to interpret but may possibly make a
certain amount of sense.
It is interesting.
I think that in the year four 96,
five,
which is to say before
the battle of La Day,
while the rebellion is still on,
uh,
the man who was elected the eponymous,
our con for that year is hip parkers,
the son of Karmas,
a relative of the Pi sister kids.
And he is precisely the
man who tradition says the,
the first ostracism was alleged
allegedly aimed at what is going on here.
Why is the, uh, the uh,
bicester it'd hit park us being elected
at this point when in fact we know that
the Persians have said that they wished
to put his relative hippiest back on the
throne.
Why would the Athenians elect this guy?
But he only interpretation makes any sense
to me is that you remember that fairy
tale I told you last time about the law
and ostracism and about how I imagined,
um,
[inaudible] he's telling him park his,
that he could avoid a lot of trouble
if he would join up with glycinate.
I think he did.
And I think his election to the art con
ship demonstrates that it's still Kleist
in these regime that is in power.
If it Parker's gets elected,
our con it must be because he's on board.
All of this is hypothesis,
but it seems to me to make sense.
The next event that we
hear about an Athens that's
relevant to our story is that
in the year for 90 see C
for 93 the Athenian Tread
Gdn franticness presents his
play called the capture of my leaders.
We don't have the play,
but we have stories about it including
one neurotic this and what the stories
say is that the,
the plague showed the scene of the taking
of my leaders and the destruction of
the city by the Persians and
that the play was so moving.
The Athenians were made so unhappy by
seeing this story that they took measures
against the playwright from making them
so miserable and find him heavily for
doing so.
What's that all about?
Well, there are various
possible interpretations,
but I think the one that's most
persuasive to me is that phrenic is knew
perfectly well,
that when he put on this play it would
cause great unhappiness and Athens and
great anger.
I,
I think he hoped it would raise anger
against the Persians and it would support
the idea of the Athenians preparing
for war against the Persians,
either in the likelihood that the Persians
would invade or that the Athenians
what has to do something
aggressively against Persia somehow.
That's,
I think that's interpretation that strikes
me as being more plausible than other
possibilities. But again, it's
only a hot pie. I hypothesis
in the same year mill tie cities comes
back to Athens having traveled from his,
uh, home in, uh, the, the, um,
deliberate peninsula and uh,
he is,
think of it for a moment. What's his
position going to be? Visa VI Persia.
It has to be anti Persian because
he has betrayed the king of Persia.
He's obviously got a price on his head.
If the Persian succeed in putting hippiest
on the throne and making Persia boss
of Athens,
his life isn't worth a nickel.
So he's got to be anti Persian.
And uh,
I think the, um, uh,
what happens next has to be understood
in terms of the political struggle in
Athens in which by no,
well not by,
oh no by no means were all
Athenians convinced that it
would be good thing to go
to the war against Persia.
I mean it's crazy.
What I want to communicate to you is the
idea of fighting against Persia now is
insane.
The Persians have conquered most of the
known world as far as the Greeks are
concerned.
They have just bashed their fellow Greeks
with without a lot of trouble in Asia
Minor. Why would you want to,
uh, take these fellows on?
What you would want is to
avoid conflict with them,
to try to find some means of
coming to terms with the Persians.
I'm sure there must've been Athenians
and carotid to says there were,
who would have preferred excepting
hippiest back as tyrant and having the
Persians be the real rulers of their
land rather than all getting killed when
the Persians decided to come after them.
So you've got these two factions,
one pro Persian,
one anti Persian,
and the fact is,
apart from hypothesis that mill
tighties is brought to trial in Athens.
The official charge against him
is of having been a tyrant in the,
uh, deliberately peninsula when he
was in charge of it there. And, uh,
he is in fact acquitted of the charge,
which may suggest if the jury was
influenced by popular opinion and had a
political view that the majority of
Athenians were not willing to take the
tyranny back in any circumstances.
And what prepared to fight.
Now that the interpretation,
again, his hypothesis,
the fact of the trial and
the acquittal are there
another interesting event is that
in the year four 93 to [inaudible],
that was one big year.
That year for 93, uh,
miss Stickley's is
elected the, uh, our con,
the eponymous art con for the year and
we shall see that some mystically is,
will play a very large role in the
great Persian invasion of for 80,
and he will be a participant in
the battle of marathon to and to,
Mister [inaudible] is a
great champion of the navy.
He has concluded for varieties of reasons
that Athens must have a much larger
navy then she already has.
And he also is obviously a member of that
faction that thinks the Persians will
becoming and that wishes to be ready and
is eager to fight against the Persians.
So [inaudible] is on the scene and one
of the things he does that looks forward
to the rest of his career is that he wants
to move the naval base of Athens from
Celeron Bay,
which is just a beach
unfortified completely open
to attack if anybody comes.
So the Athenian fleet presumably would
be drawn up on the sands of the beach at
Salieron, uh, where you can go
swimming to this very day. Um,
add. And if the those ships
are up there on the sands,
the Persian fleet come sailing up,
they're stuck.
What he wants to do is what he begins
to do to make piracy about five miles up
the road into the port of Athens,
the naval base of Athens,
it has three of its own
harvest readily protected.
If you build walls around them,
if you four to five the piracy,
then you have a port that will be secure
against an attack and also be a very
good base for moving out
of. So multidi, excuse me,
some mystical ease demonstrates what will
be his policy for the rest of his life
in regard to Athens and he,
the fact that he's chosen our con may
be indicative of the mood in Athens,
which is increasingly unwilling to accept
the idea of a return of hippiest and
the Persian rule and is
ready to fight about. Well,
by now the King of Persia has decided
that he must avenge all that has happened
and he must go after the
people who have done him harm.
Athens number one, the little
town of Eretria. Number two,
he takes a great Persian fleet,
uh,
accompanied by a great Persian army and
starts marching along the Aegean coast,
first the wet or the east coast,
and then crosses the Hellespont and
goes over onto the northern coast.
And uh, his, uh, he himself is
not doing it is his general mark.
Donius is in charge.
He conquers the regions of threes and
massive don on the north shore of the GNC.
Uh,
but in four 92,
while his fleet is lying off the
peninsula that contains Mount Athos,
one of those terrible Aegean storms that
can come up very suddenly does indeed
come up very suddenly and pretty well.
Rex,
the Persian fleet so serious is the
damage that the Persians have to abandon
their invasion of Attica,
uh,
of grease and heading
for Athens at this time.
At this I should point out is precisely
the root the Persians will take for
their major invasion in for 80.
But for the time being that has been put
off thanks to the intervention of the
storm or as the Greeks might put it,
of the gods.
Now as the Persians have actually
begun to make their invasion,
the Greek cities are aware, the Persians
are coming, the Persians are coming.
And the question is what to
do. Well, the island of Regina,
which is unfriendly to Athens,
you remember from way back,
they decide we're not going to
be swept away with the Athenians.
When the Persians get here and they
give earth and water to the king,
they have in fact become
Persian subjects at this point.
[inaudible] changes his mind.
He does not want to sit there quietly
while the Persians come and invade Greece.
And so he now goes to
the island of vagina,
takes hostages,
delivers the hostages to the Athenians,
and in so doing creates a rapprochement
between Sparta and Athens.
And now the Spartans and
the Athenians are allies.
That doesn't mean the Athenians have
joined the Peloponnesian League.
They just establish friendly relations
after being at odds for such a period of
time.
And there is a quarrel between the
two kings is, as I've told you,
and it's at this time,
that demo radius is sent into exile and
clay nominees himself comes out very
badly.
So both kings will be in some degree of
disgrace at the time of the battle of
marathon.
Oh,
let us turn them to the Persian invasion
that culminates in the battle of men of
marathon.
The purpose is very simple,
sorry to punish those cities that have
insulted and damage the great King Athens
and a retro
to restore hippies to the tyranny and
Athens and where from where he can serve
as the kings cetera and surely also to
gain a foothold in Greece on the way to
conquering all of Greece.
Why should they want to
conquer all of Greece?
Hurghada this tells a story about his
relative and tells him, for God's sake,
what do you want to go to? Greece?
There's nothing there, but a lot of rocks.
What is the point of conquering the place?
It's one thing to conquer wallabies.
Rich places Egypt Babylonia.
That's fine. This welfare,
there's huge populations is a lot of
good stuff. It's just Greeks and rocks.
Why in the world you want to go there?
And the answer I think in part would be
a Sir Edmund Hillary is answer because
they're there.
And that's part of the answer because
you know we must understand that the
ancient idea,
in fact,
I'm willing to say the idea that dominated
thinking about such matters right
down probably into the
19th century in many cases,
but certainly before the advent
of Christianity was this.
That conquest is good.
It's good to be strong, it's good to
be rich, it's good to be powerful.
Therefore it's got to be stronger,
richer and more powerful.
And if there's somebody on your frontier,
take them over, and that by the way,
will make you still more glorious
because conquest his glory.
Now we in the west,
that's not our natural attitude.
Our natural attitudes shaped
and considerable part,
whatever your religious
association may be by Christianity,
which has been the dominant force in
shaping people's thinking in the west,
whatever,
as I say,
whatever religion you belong to and that
aspect of Christianity that it violates
is the one that's increasingly the
one that's emphasized by Christians.
And that is the sermon on the mountain,
the one that says the meek
shall inherit the earth.
It's not the strong and tough and so,
and the one that says,
if your enemy strikes you, turn the other
cheek so he can strike you there too.
Now, if the Greeks had heard that, they
would've said, these people are lunatics,
send them away. Week morality
said, be good to your friend,
do good to your friends
and harm to your enemies.
And the second part is just as
important as the first part.
So you need to understand that the sort
of the ethical underpinnings to all of
our natural thinking and in the West
are as odd and strange and crazy as they
can be for everybody else in the
human race. So far as I can see,
there are exceptions.
I'm, I'm missing some, uh,
eastern religions which have ideas that
are not altogether and ask them to what
I'm saying.
But what I'm trying to say is nobody in
the ancient world would have ever had
such an idea. Of course, if
you can conquer somebody who
is your neighbor, you do.
And so there was every reason to know
that the, the Persians were coming.
Um,
how many,
we don't know.
The estimate that most people would
accept is somewhere between 20 and 30,000
infantry men. So for the sake
of splitting the difference,
I always assume something like
25,000 infantry men and some cavalry.
That's very important.
Even though the capillary does not
play any part in the actual battle of
marathon,
but Herat it,
this makes it very clear that there
was a Persian cavalry that the Persians
picked the site of marathon to fight in,
in part because it was a good
place for cavalry to fight.
So there's a Persian cavalry on board
the ships anyway, alongside the infantry,
the two Persian generals,
our datas and Arthur Fernie's,
um, they have with them.
Hippiest hippiest of course,
must've been all these years urging the
great king to make some such a campaign.
And he probably would have said,
and marathon is the place to land.
Do you remember that's the territory
of the Pi's district heads.
That's where pie sister
this landed on his last, uh,
return to Athens when he made himself
Tyron. That's where his people, where,
that's where his forces with gather.
I'm sure hippie has said what
all such exiles always say,
all I need do is set foot on the beach
at marathon and my people will rise up as
one and join me.
You won't even have to fight in Athens
because there'll be so glad to see me
back.
This is what King James,
I'm sure told Louie the 14th is
about getting back to England.
Then one, here's that all the time. Uh,
but it's a very important
part of this story.
I don't think we can understand what
happens at marathon if we don't know that
everybody thought it was highly possible
that there were Athenians who were
eager to restore hippy as to the throne
and would be willing to engage in
treasonous activities or to defect from
the democracy and join it be as if the
circumstances were appropriate.
So that's in the back of everybody's mind.
They were in the front.
I think when the Persians got there,
their strategy included the belief that
there would be treason in Athens that
would turn the city over to them
if the circumstances were right.
So that forced starts this time,
not, not, not along the coast.
As I told you last time,
it takes the shortest route directly
across the hopping from island to island,
stops it in that sauce.
Member Nexus in Noida King by
successfully resisting are staggering,
is a invasion and they destroy next sauce.
Next they come to the island of
deloss in the middle of the Aegean,
the island sacred to Apollo and his
sister artimus a very sacred place indeed
for the Greeks.
What to the versions?
Do they treat the arc?
I'm not the article,
but they treat the deacons
and the priests of Apollo,
the loss with great respect,
do them no harm.
This is typical Persian conquest.
They do not impose religions.
Their religion is different from that
of most of the others in this area.
They are Zoroastrians.
They are sun worshipers of
a certain con. Uh, and uh,
but they don't impose their religion.
They don't interfere with their religion.
They get a very nice writeup in
the Old Testament, if you remember,
because they don't mistreat the Hebrews
and they particularly don't do them,
uh,
in compelled them to abandon their own
religious practices as the other invaders
do. So what is, uh, what,
what are the Persians
saying by these actions?
They are saying we are not
at war with the Greek gods.
We're not even at war with the Greeks.
We are simply punishing these two Ms
Korean towns that have attacked us.
They then turn to the southern tip of
the island of Euboea to the town of
characters. The persons may
be not at war with the Greeks,
but they expect all Greeks or along the
way to behave the way they're supposed
to,
to the great king.
And so they asked the Corinthians to
give Earth and water they're Corinthians
refuse and the Persians,
oh, obliterate. Uh,
but their city and take
their people into slavery.
Now they push their way,
take their sale along the coast of
Euboea to Eretria in the north east.
And now here are 4,000 Athenians
settled there. Remember?
In a clarification. So right. They, uh,
get their armor on and they stand in
front and a prepared to dub die fighting
for the freedom of Eretria because of
their wonderful friendship to Athens.
Wrong.
The 4,000 Athenians go home to Attica.
Why? Well, I suppose the
immediate answer is why not?
But the,
it's an embarrassment and Hirata at this,
I think we have to realize is very
friendly to Athens all throughout his own
history. I doubt that there's, I mean,
there's no doubt that
he spent time in Athens.
He seems to have been a friend
of Paraclese in later years.
He was kindly,
although he himself comes from
helicopter Nassis in Asia Minor,
but he did, he did spend a
lot of time in Athens and uh,
there seems to be a pro Athenian cast.
One thing also is that many of his,
um, sources were Athenians
who told the story their way.
So their answer was the Athenians were
ready to fight to save Eretria but the
retro Ian said is no point. Why should
you get killed too? It's not your town.
Why don't you go home if you can
believe that you can believe anything.
But I don't. I think the Athenians
realized there was nothing but disaster.
If they stayed in, they could
believe if we get back to Attica,
we might be able to make a contribution
to defending our city. Okay,
so now here they are at Eretria,
the Athenians are gone.
It's time for the invasion,
the site of the battle.
Where do they go? Well, they
picked marathon as I say,
in part because it's very near
Eretria. Secondly, as a Herata says,
because it's a good place for cavalry.
Thirdly, as I've already told you,
because it's the stronghold of Pi Sisters,
the place which would be natural for an
army trying to establish hippiest on the
throne of that.
That's why they're there.
And their plan I think
is to go to marathon.
If the Pussy Athenians come out
and challenge them to a fight,
they will crush the Athenians.
But they didn't expect that.
They thought the Athenians
would be afraid, but,
and that what would happen is they would
stay there in marathon until they got
the news that there was
a revolution in Athens,
prepare to turn the city over to them.
That's what hit me is I think led them to
believe in. That's what they hoped for.
They were prepared to fight of course,
but they thought it wouldn't be necessary.
So on August the fourth,
they land in the year for 90 at marathon.
We know these dates
because there are, uh, uh,
as an eclipse associated with this,
which allows astronomers
to fix it pretty precisely.
The Athenians of course,
when they knew that the Persians were
coming and that news would have come to
them, the minute they got to Mac sauce,
then ships would have come to Athens.
So the seniors were well worn,
went to their new friends,
Sparta to ask them for help.
Of course.
And this is where a
wonderful stories they sent.
The great runner who's named comes
down to us in the manuscripts as five
[inaudible]. Chances are his
real name was Phillip cities,
but there was an error in the manuscript,
but we'll call him five deputies cause
that's what the manuscripts say. And uh,
he um,
he races to Sparta as fast as he could go.
Took them less than two days where
he came to the Spartans and he said,
the Persians are coming, the Persians
are coming. Please help us. The Spartan.
We would love to come and
help you. Nothing would
please us more. Unfortunately,
we are in the midst of our holy religious
ceremony that cornea and we are not
allowed until to leave our
hometown until the next full moon,
which is a matter of fact, is
the night of August 11th, 12th.
In other words,
a whole week after the,
the Persians are going to land,
I can't go speculating as to what
are we to make of this? Is this me?
Is this just an excuse of the Spartan
series about this? Our tendency,
I suppose being modern and cynical
would be to say it's only an excuse.
I'm more inclined to think that
they were sincere about it.
It's not that they couldn't find
ways to get round such things,
but they really took their religion quite
seriously. And it may be that, uh, uh,
you know,
that did play a role,
be that as it may two things
that the Athenians now know,
they know the Spartans have promised
to come, but not for another week.
Both of those things should be, uh, on
your minds as you try to understand.
Now,
[inaudible] says that the Athenian army
marched out from Athens and went to
marathon, and then they had an
argument about what they should do.
But I don't think that's right.
There must have been a debate.
There had to be a debate in Athens.
You couldn't take an army out of town
without having an assembly to argue the
question, should we send an army?
And if we should send an army,
how big should the army be?
And having that decided that
who should be in command.
All those things had to be
settled by the assembly in Athens.
So that's where the debate took place.
Some favored defending the city of Athens.
Now we don't know how well
the city of Athens was walled,
defended by fortification
at this time in its history.
It may not have had any wall,
but I'd be surprised.
But it certainly did not have a wall that
was guaranteed to be effective against
an attack.
And so I think we should understand that
is not going to be successful to stay
home and defend the Athens means to allow
the Persians to run all around Attica
doing anything they want,
causing all the harm.
They could remember something over 75%
maybe as many as 90% of the Athenians had
farms out in the country.
Now the houses out in the country that
would have been exposed to the Persians,
and so there was good reason for them
not to think that was a great idea.
The alternative was to send an army out
to allow the Persians to land because
they couldn't stop it. They didn't know
where the Persians were going to come,
but as soon as they heard
that the Persians had landed
to send an army there and
meet them at the place of landing mill.
Tinies emerges as the leading figure here.
Not because,
I mean he is in general,
but that's not the only reason.
It's because everybody knows
mill [inaudible] is the
resident Persian expert.
He has been a general in the Persian army.
And so that gives him a come,
a reason to be listened to.
But he's obviously also a person of
great merit and quality proves it at the
battle of marathon. Uh, he
must've been an impressive fellow.
So for all these reasons,
whatever his formal position was,
and I think it was simply
one of the generals de facto,
he had much more influence
than others for these reasons.
And his argument was let us go out and
meet the Persians where they land and the
reasons where we,
we don't want them to be able to get
to the Spartans. But beyond that,
there was fear that if we stay home and
wait and let the Persians do whatever
they're going to do every day,
that passes increases the danger of
treason from those people who want to turn
the city over.
Um,
and it's also so completely against
the ethic of the Greek warrior.
And I would say more
specifically the hoplite warrior.
You don't let your enemy
ravage your countryside.
You don't let them destroy your farm.
This in a way,
goes all the way back to,
to homer, the notion of RFA.
A man must have courage.
He must stand up against an
enemy who invades his country.
And then again beyond that,
you move to the world of the hoplite
and you're talking about defending your
homestead. All of that argument
for going out there. So,
uh,
the terminology I would use for modern
terminology to explain what the Athenian,
that strategy was to go out
and to contain the beachhead,
go out,
confront us Persians where they are,
don't let them get inland
from where they landed.
So they do land at marathon
with about 2,500 infantry.
And I remember their
infantry are not hoplites,
they do not have heavy armor.
There are pictures on a
wonderful paintings on vases.
Yes sir. I meant thousand, I hope by yeah,
thanks very much. Um, there,
there are visas that showed the Persian
soldiers at marathon and they are
wearing a pants as I told you.
But then at carrying any,
uh,
they're not wearing any armor and their,
their shield is a kind of a wicker
shield so that their armament is much
inferior to the hoplites.
And keep in mind too that the Persian
army is always made up of a collection of
subject peoples. Yes,
there will be some Persian,
but there will also be a lots of
folks who are not Persians in there.
So they lacked that unity that the Greeks,
we'll have
the,
excuse me,
I got this thing a little backwards.
Well, nevermind. Um,
mealtime.
Andy's plan is this,
there are something like 10,000 Greeks
about 9,000. That's ain't aliens.
About a thousand are veterans against,
let us say 25,000 Persians.
And so, uh, as the thing begins,
the map here shows you the rough
picture of the field at marathon here.
The Persians landed right here and had
their ships drawn up at this place.
They had their camp behind here.
This Marshall,
would it be a little bit more over
this way? It's a very serious,
Marsha will play an important role
in what happens. The Greeks come out,
they'd probably bully.
Came marching in through this way.
And here we have mountains.
This wavy line indicates
the line of the mountains.
Here you have a really flat plane,
but here you have mountains.
And somewhere up on the hills here,
there was the Greek camp near them.
Modern Church of Saint Demetrius.
This little dot reflects
the mound where the dead,
the Greek dead at marathon will
after the battle be buried.
And that is likely to be about the
place with a main fighting took place,
which helps us to place where the
actual battle took place. So the,
the idea of the, uh, of the, uh,
Athenians was to try to hold
him there as long as they could.
But the Greeks have the upper hill,
the Persians are down below.
If the Persians want to start a fight,
then they ought to come that they
will have to come running up the hill.
Well, that is not a very attractive
proposition. And so the Greeks feel,
let them come for us. It's our country.
They're sitting here on the thing.
They've got to do something.
We don't. Meanwhile,
the Persians are waiting for treason.
So if the city will be
surrendered to them,
a week goes by with the two sides
looking at each other and doing nothing.
I always like to compare the Athenian
strategy to an old fashioned football
strategy,
which I haven't seen done now in decades,
which used to be kick on first
down and wait for a fumble.
In other words, let give the ball to the
Persians and let them make a mistake.
Uh, I think that's what was
in mill tighties mind. Well,
time passes and the Persians realize we
can't sit there forever. For one thing,
they're going to run out of food
and water for another thing.
The great king will want to
hear something. Well, how'd
you do? What did you do?
We sat there and watched the these scenes.
No good.
So the plan that the Persians made, I
think was this, that they would take,
let us say for the sake of argument,
10,000 troops,
put them on the ships, load
up the cavalry with, uh,
onto the ships to and send those ships
around Attica to come up to fallow on
bay, straight into Athens. And meanwhile,
take the 15,000 that are left,
March them up too close,
as close as you could get to the Greeks
and fix the Greeks there so that they
can't go back and defend, uh, Athens.
So there's no army to protect assets.
So if those guys get off the ships,
come sailing into the harbor,
walk up to town, it's theirs.
If the Athenians are crazy enough from
the Persian point of view to come running
down the hill or walking down
the hill of whatever into,
to be outnumbered three to two
by us in any way are Persians,
we always beat Greeks. We've got nothing
to worry about, then, uh, let him do it.
So they come now [inaudible] he's
in charge on the day of the battle,
he's got the problem that they
have 5,000 more troops than he has.
He's worried about being outflanked.
So what each decides to do is to weaken
the depths of his line because he must
cover the length of the Persian line.
Well,
the danger with that is of course,
that when they hit each other,
the Persians will break through the Greek
lines. So instead of making it even,
he loaded up the wings and left the
center even weaker than it would otherwise
have been.
His hope and strategy was
that the Athenians would
win on the wings before the
Persians could break through the middle
and then the Athenians could turn on the
center of the Persians and to feed them
and just barely. That's what happened.
The Persians did break through the
center, but it was too late. By that time,
the Greek wing,
the Athenian Wings were successful
and drove the Persians before them.
The Persians ran away like mad,
but they ran into the great swamp
and that made their escape much more
difficult. So the Athenians were
able to kill great numbers of them.
And finally that that battle was
over and now the battle was over.
Let's imagine that it took a couple
of hours. That would be a long time.
The Athenians had time now to have a meal,
take a little rest and
March back across to Attica,
which ad before the ships could get there.
And I like to imagine the
scene when it all happened.
The Persians coming around the last bend
of the bay as they coming to Fowler on
expecting to see a nice empty
beach and seeing the Athenian army.
I liked them.
Imagine with their left foot in the
breakers and their shields up in there,
uh,
spears up with the sun gleam off their
shields and blinding the Persians as they
came.
And at which point you can't force a
landing against an army just can't be done
in the ancient world.
These guys had to go home and start
thinking about what they're going to tell
the great king.
The Athenians won the battle.
Very large, very large, uh,
casualties for the Persians.
Only 192 Greeks killed in the battle
and allowed the extraordinary honor of,
um, being buried on the field
where they bet have fought.
Next Day,
2000 Spartans come marching into Attica
that proves they were serious and were
told what had happened.
They asked permission,
can we go to the
battlefield and look at it?
And there they saw all these dead
Persians and no one had ever seen anything
like that.
No Greeks that ever beat Persians before.
And Great was the glory of the Athenians.
So I've described very
inadequately in to swiftly.
The battle was so what?
What is the significance
of this silly little Babel,
10,000 Greeks against the 15,000
Persians back a billion years ago?
What does it matter? And Lots of folks
will tell you that, especially these days,
but I remember in 1936,
there was a,
a wonderful conference of pacifists,
uh,
who met in England at which the dominant
theme of the speakers was no war ever
made any difference.
What I like about that was that the
place of the meeting was Hastings.
The battle was seen throughout
the rest of Greek history.
First of all is a great victory for
hoplites as opposed to their opponents in,
in later Greek history. When the
navy, when the Athenian history,
when the navy becomes a big
thing, it is the, the party,
the old fashioned and more conservative
party that thinks about marathon as the
great victory that day that those
hoplite farmers saved Greece,
the navy guys,
the poor like to think about Salomon,
the naval battle in for Haiti,
it was seen as a victory for democracy.
It was the Athenian Democrats later on.
I'm sure there were glad
the per the Spartans never
got there because they could
claim it as their own and as a
victory for democracy as well.
It was also the first,
as I say,
Greek defeat of the Persians as
Hurghada and says for up until then,
even the name of Persians was a
fearful thing for Greeks to here.
It was the source of tremendous national
pride and glory for Athens and scholars
have compared the impact of the battle
of marathon on the Athenian image of
themselves with the defeat of the Spanish
armada by Elisabeth's English fleet,
uh, and the beginning of the
glory of the Elizabethan era.
It was seen as a victory for freedom
because the price of the feet would have
been slavery in every sense
as they understood it.
Greek civilization,
and I'll come back to this in a minute,
could have been strangled in it's
infancy because it is in its infancy,
but again,
we ought to pay attention to those people
who suggest that people like me are
over embellishing the
significance of all this.
One English statesman said,
war wins, nothing cures,
nothing settles nothing.
Speaker was Neville Chamberlain
and 90 36 Bertrand Russell philosophy
declared disarmament and complete pacifism
is indisputably the wisest policy and
he urged the gradual disbanding of the
British Army, navy and air force as
Hitler was moving into the Rhineland.
Does victory in war make a difference?
I would say as the losers,
the victims and the survivors
of the Holocaust ask the
descendants of the slaves
in the American south.
Remember this,
if the Athenians had lost at Marathon
East Golez had just begun his career as a
playwright.
Sophocles hadn't written a play.
Your deputies of course hadn't either,
nor had Aristophanes
Socrates pick up this, right?
Yeah.
Socrates wasn't born yet,
much less Plato, Aristotle, Phineas.
There was no Parthenon.
None of those glorious buildings
that we make us think about.
The greatness that was
Greece had been constructed.
There would be no democracy because
this was the only place where it had any
existence.
The scientific revolution,
which was almost in beyond,
beyond it's infancy in terms of being new,
uh,
would have been wiped out.
There would be no memory.
There would be no record of any of this,
and therefore no Western civilization,
no political freedom for all these have
occurred in no other culture in all the
years since that time.
That's why I wanted you to know a
little bit about the battle of Marathon,
because I think all of
us alive today here, oh,
a very great debt to the
10,000 marathoner Mccoy,
the fighters of marathon,
who fought for Greek
freedom and for hours too.